josh and i were talking about making a
tomahawk steak i mean look at this bad
boy come on
this is where i just turn into like
an animal
um
[Laughter]
well i thought that since josh and i
want to cook a tomahawk steak that maybe
we should turn to one of the world's
greatest experts because you may know
him from simon's dinner's cooking out
and barbecue brawl flay versus simon i
mean come on it's michael simon
hey hey josh what's going on how are you
guys
great michael lovely to be here with you
josh josh michael josh you i could
listen to you talk all day you are
incredibly soothing so i'm very excited
to show you and drew how to make the
steak and the tomahawk the thing about a
tomahawk because i feel it's a little
bit of a celebratory steak uh but the
key to cooking it is it's a big thick
steak so how do you cook a big thick
steak to add the most amount of flavor
and uh to to really cook it evenly we do
a reverse sear on it and a reverse ears
is cooking mistake at a very slow
temperature in your oven um like 225
with some
aromatics that you like i'm using
rosemary and garlic so this allows the
cook the steak to cook very slowly and
evenly all the way through you get it to
about 10 degrees less than the
temperature you want to finish it at and
then you pull it out to finish it either
in a cast iron or on the grill so
if i if you like your steak how do you
like your steak josh
well i think i do my medium medium rare
but i do the exact same thing except for
what i was doing and you helped me if
i'm doing it wrong was putting it on you
know the the
um ledge above a barbecue so i put it on
the barbecue sort of at a lower
temperature put it on the ledge for you
know a while 45 minutes or so and then
brought it down basically and finished
it off that way so exactly
you're doing the exact same thing it's a
perfect method so i just brush the
outside of this with extra virgin oil
then with the steak this cup thick
you're gonna have to be pretty liberal
with your salt i'm just using kosher
salt here
and then if you wanted to do cracked
black pepper you could do cracked black
pepper
um but that's that's more of a choice
and then i create a little bed i put
some garlic cloves underneath
i put some rosemary underneath and then
i also do the same thing on top i just i
leave the skins on the garlic slightly
smash it with my hand put it on top and
then we cover that in the rosemary also
then this goes in our 225 degree oven
um for roughly 45 minutes or until you
get to the temperature that you want to
get to okay this um by the way smells so
good the garlic and the rosemary
i'm a big fan of fried rosemary too this
is beautiful oh delicious and once you
pull it out
we could go right to our cast iron pan
with it beautiful that looks fantastic
so now i have my cast iron on about
medium-high heat so we're just gonna
take off
our garlic and our rosemary take it out
i'm gonna take this steak yeah i'm gonna
take the steak and i'm just gonna put it
right in the pan
and you could hear the smears
michael on a steak like this
approximately like how long ish to a
side on the average depending on the
heat of the pan the size of steak three
to five minutes okay perfect because the
crust
yeah outside because the crust really
adds that maximum flavor um
you can see it's running out some of
that fat look at my crust now look at
that see that that's what we're talking
about yes
it's perfect so now i'm gonna put my
rosemary and garlic back in this pan
and now this is one last great trick i'm
just gonna take some butter and i'm
going to put the butter in the pan and
as that butter melts
i'm going to take the butter and baste
it over my steak because the butter is
going to take on the flavor of the
rosemary and the garlic so now we take
that melted butter
and we just
we just throw it on top
and as you put it over the steak it's
infusing some of that garlic and
rosemary in there but it's also kind of
reinforcing our crust oh you can smell
it from here oh look at that and josh
your new movie murderous trance um what
was that like i mean i hope this isn't a
spoiler you're a bad guy yeah he's a
great bad guy i mean in the sense of
just uh as a maniacal cult leader type
personality it was bizarre to make
because i you know drew you get these
little
weird uh tricks that we learned and that
one i was so jet-lagged making that
movie that i realized it was really
helping me um so i decided basically i
didn't sleep for a full eight days and i
looked worse and worse and my
performance became better and better
but now i have a quick i have a quick
little funny story here about e.t like
my little boy and i when we watched bt
i i convinced him that e.t was living in
the north woods of central park and so
we would go to the woods of central park
and we would search for e.t and i would
i would basically let him go in front of
me and i would just occasionally throw a
pine cone at him and i was like that's a
tea bts like it was it was the most fun
it was such a wonderful uh we did it
probably like so just a week for a
couple months well in search of e.t you
know what that tells me
that you're a good dad
absolutely i i agree with that comment a
hundred percent yeah so then what i do
when we were talking i cut out that
outside cap like where the fat runs i
cut that off that's the decal that is
the cap of the steak the most delicious
part of any steak um it's the part that
like i always want to eat um but i give
to my friends because i'm kind but
that's the most flavorful part and then
the rest of it you could just slice down
right through
oh my god it is perfect and then i just
like to finish it with some like crunchy
sea salt florida cell a little bit of
extra virgin olive oil
drizzled on top and that's it you know
yeah it's delicious
yeah
it's incredible i feel guilty very
jealous you guys i know that's why i'm
like it's okay
my mouth is truly watering um yeah
exactly
you guys this was so informative i feel
like i got really like no
bs life-changing tips and
i just thank you both gentlemen for
this wonderful meaningful awesome groovy
cool time together thanks you guys thank
you michael so much michael simon on
cameo and all proceeds benefit the
michael d simon foundation and directly
help the restaurant industry which needs
it so much right now and thank you josh
lucas murderous trance will hit vod in
all digital platforms where movies are
sold on february 9th
thanks
guys thank you
[Music]